suhaka me moved here so my mom could
work at the college what about your dad
that's the other reason we moved you
know my mom says we shouldn't be in Lost
Creek woods she says some parts are
dangerous it's not dangerous I'm still
new here can anyone tell me something
interesting about living in Bracken Vale
the woods near my house is haunted
someone's supposed to have died out
there in the woods like 20 years ago
mom let's go across
I heard that there's a monster that
lives really deep in the woods on the
other side of the creek that's stupid
there's my don't want to go across what
about all the missing people
what missing me my neighbors your
neighbors aren't missing well something
was going on you're right you've got a
crazy imagination
don't go cross the peak Peter why
don't okay Thomas Peter
if once you next I don't think it's
gonna stop until it gets you
gotta fight it don't we what are you
crazy
some things don't go away when you stop
attending
you
the wrong people to trick-or-treat
winces you